Hello everybody my name is Markiplier,
And welcome back to Oxygen Not Included.
Now, I've made some progress we're pretty
-much to the same place where we left off,
but I made some changes and some progress
that we're going to be focusing on. Right
now, my biggest problem is that we're
running out of food and this whole place
is running out of oxygen so I opened up
this area to try to let some things
transfer through but- uh, in the end there's
another problem, because we just don't have
nearly enough oxygen production and then
carbon dioxide is just building up through out of
-here. I'm trying to build beds for them up
here so hopefully they're gonna have a
little less horrifying time and oh my
god. What the fuck just happened
there?
ohhhhh okaaaay then that's gross
Oh boy! Let's bring another person
into this hellhole. Yeah, why not.
"gastraphobia can't perform cook" Well
that's okay.
"divers lungs" That's what we need! People
that can't breathe.
We're gonna go with you Stacy, come on
in here Stacy!  Welcome to hell. (literally)
Alright so I've gotta- I'm just
continuing the plan, like I would have
said it like a- i'm continuing but I
did construct all this stuff here
because- I obviously wasn't necessary
over there, this going well over here,
(mark giggles) I say as Olive vomits again. Just a good
stress response, you know, not too bad
nothing shabby about that one. Um, but so
long as we got this here we're going to
eventually have algae delivery and I
know that they're going to be able to
get it because it's right here and right
here so when they do get it they'll be able
to put it in these and hopefully keep
these running. Uh, water is running low
though. We are almost out of water here,
and I have to have a system in place to
get water before we run out of water so
that's my next step for this one because
if we don't, we're in trouble.
And this is broken again, great. Kay, atleast those are
going four of those should be able to do a
good number on producing oxygen, and then
the next step will be making beds, so that they
they have a good place to sleep on the
priority nine those uh yeah yeah and
then hopefully one more down here we can
build a better sanitation area with
actual plumbing and one not your
grandfather's but I do not know
also I'm pretty sure slime when it
converted into algae and produces
contaminated water so I mean while that
may not seem ideal what that does mean
is that it does produce water so that is
good so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to produce I'm gonna start the plans for
this I'm gonna build an eruv wire use
nori okay I'm gonna build an airlock
over there because i just kind of like
this was being you know a natural
separation but there's slime over here
so hopefully got the same thing
everytime got the one thing you can't
break God not dammit guts out of
whatever we're doing our best to we're
doing our best doing our best
we're all in this together you're
nervous you're nervous kind of
prioritize the connection of that are
you know what I'm going to build I need
to try to handle this stress situation
because all these people have a lot of
problems interrupted sleep new friend
stepped in contaminated water granny
dirty hands so we need a lot of things
to try to fix that missing resource
bleach stone
no kidding so what we got to do is I'm
going to prioritize this area here is
going to be the Sanitation area
it just has to be because otherwise but
we're not going to do anything
whoa what is with that what is represent
all my god
oh whoa what is revolver that mop it up
recycling I guess that dampens the
battery you could just figure out take a
breather max my fav to continue breaking
your shit okay good
don't do that boy that's a lot of
vomiting happening
you're all going to thank me when we go
over is tough love is learning through
suffering that's the thing that happens
right that's the thing that's the thing
that parents do they make their kids
suffer and then they learn that's how it
works right
I thought that's how it works i think i
think i'm pretty sure that was a pretty
ok so now we need to unleash this lime
really all i want to do is I want to
just dig out so that some slime is
exposed actually I don't even know if
this reaches help i'm just going to dig
literally this just a tiny fraction well
actually prioritize the airlock first
and then do this okay
they're not grammar we need algae holy
shit we are almost dead in the water for
oxygen God gaming no algae Rick no
accident was done here there's nothing
in there
this area is too big to contain it all I
guess we just don't really have enough
out the terrariums to be able to do this
I know how dieter areum's are probably a
less intensive algae consumer and
probably these things are extremely
because they probably just burn the
algae while these things grow the algae
I just don't I'm I'm just pretty sure
that be still would consume algae but
probably at a slower rate so what we
gotta do i guess i just got to focus on
them
we're getting some algae out of that
what we know and fall to their death
please don't be too stupid and quality
your deaths ok so those are going
that's good they just need water and
then they're good yeah that's the thing
that they consume they just consume
water no matter what you're running out
of one resource or another release the
slime who lime is releasing maybe don't
stay in there what are you doing in
there
why are you in there oh you can't get
back
oh shit oh no they stranded would be
easier to build a ladder would be easier
oh my god we need to build a ladder that
would probably the easiest way to get
out other than like tile what is what is
the tile need oh boy okay so who know I
think that I'll might be easier because
then you just need these three tiles
their cancel these prioritize these I
think these are left material intensive
to go for that everything else is lower
priority I oh my god I can't believe I
just ship okay all right then right
please let him get out let him get out
come on mon there we go get out get out
get out go go go go okay I saved and I
saved you guys stop taking a breath and
just go nori stop it out of there
ok so all the oxygen terrariums are
going they're doing pretty good i guess
i can make the fuck some aggression out
again
yeah you okay but you guys are going to
survive and you're gonna thank me for
this
I mean you're obviously not gonna thank
me for this but eventually you're gonna
thank me maybe you're okay well well one
crisis cross have solved internet more
to go boy
so now i really really really got to
think about water because if I don't
everyone that I know I keep saying that
but that's literally how this goes i got
to get him water so i gotta-i gotta
figure plumbing out of its plumbing
works and then the carbon dioxide
scrubber is now in the wrong place but
it's whatever you still at work so i
gotta figure out what you want
what does it want like what do you want
don't get it like this the liquid pump
does it want em cheap I don't get it
Oh least everyone has a bad run the
dreaming of food though they're probably
starving gonna figure out a way to get
more food but everyone keeps breaking
everything before I'm actually able to
do anything so what we're going to do
just for the sake of stress relief
we're going to make it a massage table
just everybody you want to besides come
down to the algae terrarium and have
yourself a lovely old side also we're
going to build lamps you guys like lamps
right i like when you like lamps i love
land
alright everything in here tomorrow this
is your priority make all this shit to
do that you can do that are good for you
alright for gas problem i don't know
what that's going to do
no wire connected of course not why
would there be Oh they do need wire why
wouldn't they
that's nice ok and then connect that to
this
alright your massage tables need
anything they don't seem to need power
hopefully they can do is blast out since
trails the duplicates are carrying a lot
of tension in there everything i'm aware
i'm aware he's breaking it as they're
running on it
good job and then you shit yourself
great didn't know you guys are great you
guys world love you guys
death okay this makes no sense I'm gonna
obviously I'm doing something wrong with
this so I'm just gonna adjust I just
figure this out later because obviously
I'm doing something is very wrong and I
don't want to do it until I gotta write
at least we got massage table here so if
anybody wants a massage
hey god lady you want to side stable
owners oh I get it
we've got an incredible food shortage an
outstandingly bad food shortage
starvation of who's starving Lenny on no
Lenny was getting more stressed i don't
know i know i'm giving the way there was
a stable does obviously going to be
there before you know yeah
you alright so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna build big beefy batteries so
hopefully people actually to lash out
like maybe we can get some stories about
all my God look at the light
well yeah look it up we are flying by
it's so bride down there whoo
oh yes welcome another one to the fold
when we don't have enough food and this
broken track
come on max dammit max of course the
parents and repair this too because
they're all broken everyone's that max
stress even even the new person is going
to be an absolute max dress and stop
advanced java java band
okay fine whatever do you think i'm
going to build more micro brushes
because I just like the ones are kind of
these big batteries hopefully one of
them will be able to run I got a time
but honestly who knows man another
manual generator expose all right bring
out of bourbon and why not let's bring
someone else
ah good Virgil of position we could use
that voice will come on in here it's bad
it's it's it's bad in eretz it's pretty
damn batted it's real bad it is like
real bad but we got this
so you guys believe in me out there too
i know you do I know you really do I
know yet hundred percent think that I'm
definitely confident and capable of the
leader to lead these people into life
you know the hard challenge of staying
alive pneus so to build the algae algae
conversion you need to be able to have
the just the bio destruction the bio
distiller needs power and then a place
to shunt all of the contaminated water
and that's it that's literally all it is
so if the bio distiller is say right
outside the door and we could possibly
build or maybe if the bio distillers
right here and then I could
with those things maybe the body fillers
here
I don't know ok so what I'm gonna do is
for the storage sake the storage is
right outside this door and that's where
the slime is going to go eventually
we'll go get this guy who produces all
the slime we want the right now we're
just going to bring the harvesting it
then from there we are going to make
sure that they can get to this area here
and then we're going to build once we do
this try to these things
goddammit Oh will they stop hitting that
one battery we gotta connect this bad
boy here organizing structure
maybe I should assign ok that's Lenny
know you max show the ELSA stress your
VAT all live probably meet by know
you're stressed oh man on the guys
oh man but that means there's not enough
like this is not enough for everybody
who say i don't know how these work I
just don't know
ok looks like powers back up that's nice
all right go for it goes the power of
the whole shebang don't you oh you need
okay we're making wish bars were making
nothing but much bars because we need
food we need lots of food
I've there's one thing i do is provide
for my foodies so they're gonna get food
okay we've done so now we can make the
the converter the bio distiller which
could then can just pump it can just
hump extroyer this and then obviously
these aren't she
figures out here I mean they're
providing oxygen and then there's no
oxygen in here but they don't really
need to go in there for very long and
the biota still can just dump water
straight down the bottom and then the
shebang boom we got a steady supply of
algae right that's how it works right
that's how it works that's all I know
we're just gonna pump these straight
down that's all its gonna be
oh look at all moje oh hell yeah you
getting less stress buddy boo
hey guys how you feeling who guesses at
94 all that's much better
alright then we got the Bible still is
going up there if they need power I
don't think they need power because
they're all they do need power okay so
they're gonna need their own individual
power source will just have manual
generator here and one big battery there
and kill the crowd and eventually one
more okay those are going to do their
thing then we'll have algae finally have
algae so this is only literally only for
slut
this is only first one that's the only
thing is for that's the only thing it
will be for and that's all we're going
to use that for
oh look at that again miscarriages
they're getting the fuses good for them
good for them good for bama oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
okay so that means fill this one cuz
these are all getting a little bonus
from the extra light because they're
like directly under a light source
that's kind of good
these are going to get built soon
stress vomiting i know i know i know i
know i know i know i'm well aware of
this i am aware
ok so i need to what i need to do though
Lenny said
died of starvation
I'm really fast
we lost one
man
max you just got a massage your in
morning I get it on no no broke
something that immediately got a massage
I get it
these have got to be like you gotta be
high priority we just need weed mush
that's all we need we just need to push
so anyway now that we got that out of
the way you can start harvesting the
slime
I don't know if these are going to
produce contaminated oxygen while
they're doing and I'm assuming they are
but eventually we will need to need to
seal it off in Lenny's right there on
the ground
we're almost out of water here
he's not going to be the last not going
to be the last to die of hot and iconic
save them
I yelled in Lenny so much feel bad for
Lenny at least things are falling into
place
I suppose may not seem like it but
things are falling into place
it was still mad he was still stretched
I know everyone everyone stress I'm well
aware
oh but i think i managed happens out
here because what else can I do so thank
you everybody so much for watching this
is i'm trying my best here i'm trying to
salvage this
we're getting there but it's a slow
process
it's a slow process but we are getting
there
thank you everybody so much for watching
as always an see you in the next video
bye bye!
*Markiplier's outro music*